I need to tell you something right now
is it about UFOs yes but this is super
real and super important can't just
cling to any UFO news and say aliens are
real I'm not saying aliens are real
someone else is so there was a
whistleblower and there was a hearing oh
my God can I just say it don't say it
well I really want to say is their proof
is there hard evidence because
scientifically no but everyone's talking
about Bionicles biologics can I just say
it please I'll admit this is all pretty
interesting yes but you can't just say
it aliens are real we have 100 Proof
they are real happy now you're not just
gonna move on to another story
immediately once people get bored are
you no but hey did you know five ways uh
the 2024 election could be affected by
inflation okay